lawmakers are still working on a deal to
close out negotiations on a nearly
trillion dollar coveted relief package
it would provide more than three hundred
billion dollars in aid to small
businesses
three hundred dollars a week in federal
jobless benefits
and six hundred dollars in individual
stimulus checks
joining us now from capitol hill the
number three republican
in the senate john barrasso senator
where do we stand on covid relief talks
i understand there's a lot of
parliamentary rigamarole
but what are the chances that all sides
will sign on
to an agreement today this gets done
today no more delays we're not leaving
until we have relief for the american
people people are hurting people need
help and there are two things we need to
do
to write this final chapter on
coronavirus and the one
is to get people vaccinated we're doing
that now
20 million people will be vaccinated by
the end of this
by by new year's eve but we need to
provide help for the american public
people who've been struggling
until we get enough people vaccinated
that we can fully get the economy back
on track and that means people back to
work and kids back to school
so direct payment checks to the american
people six hundred dollars
for people who are watching chris if
they got a check last time
they will get a check again this time
adults and children
for people who are out of work through
no fault of their own three hundred
dollars a week for enhanced unemployment
going into next year and for the small
businesses
and the working families all across
america
we were going to do more paycheck
protection loans so those small
businesses can stay
open so people can get paychecks all the
way through
this has been a very successful program
13
000 small businesses in wyoming have
used this
program it's a little more specific this
time
in that the business has to be fewer
than 300 employees
and they actually have to show a loss
but that's the way
we get this disease behind us
i i want to just hone down on one point
specifically i know that you worked out
the issue
about emergency lending authority to the
fed but then
just after midnight uh last night this
morning
president trump said he wanted to see
the direct payments higher
bigger than the three 600 uh dollars to
each american who got one last time i
take it you're not going to go along
with
changing that part of the program we
need to get this
done today the president is right in
that this is no fault of the american
people
chris we should have done this months
ago had not nancy pelosi played politics
through the fall
because of the presidential election
she's admitted as much
we've had a bill pretty comparable to
what we're going to pass
today and we've offered it by
republicans
time and time again the democrats beat
it down 40 different times
this has been wrong the delay has been
too long we need to get it done
now for christmas
after the electoral college voted
this week to make joe biden the next
president of the united states senator
mitch mcconnell addressed the issue
on the senate floor here's what he said
the electoral college has spoken
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden
you were asked that same day uh
whether or not joe biden is now the
president-elect and you
dismissed it as a gotcha question how
senator is it a gotcha to ask who is
going to be
the president one month from today
well first you know how the press is
sometimes in the halls of congress if
you don't give a one-word answer they're
not satisfied
um i talked to them about the fact of
the constitution
article two section one uh and the uh
twelfth amendment to the constitution
and
i accept what has happened in the
election and with the electoral college
i was one of over 70 percent of the
people of wyoming
proud to help and vote for president
trump
over 70 million americans have done that
he's done remarkable things
i don't believe we would have a vaccine
today if it weren't for president
trump's determination
and to end all of those so that didn't
turn out the way i wanted it to
but the electoral college has now
certified the election we have the
constitution and i accept
the outcome of the election well so let
me ask you directly
will joe biden be the next president of
the united states
yes he will
you accept that i do
okay that wasn't so hard
you wrote an article for the wall street
journal recently in which you criticized
how democrats delayed
confirming members of the trump cabinet
uh in the month he came in in january of
2017. i want to put up on the screen
what you wrote
mr clinton had 13 out of 14 in january
when he came in mr obama 11 out of 15.
senate democrats made sure mr trump only
had
three senator are you going to
play the democrats game of delay what
they did to donald trump back in 2017
or can you promise swift confirmation of
his nominees and are there any of the
names you've heard so far
who you consider dead on arrival well a
couple of things it looks like the biden
cabinet would be a third term of the
obama administration and
that didn't sit really well in wyoming
we have a role
to advise and consent on these nominees
which is why the election coming up in
georgia
is so critical in the control of the
senate why i want to make sure that
kelly lefler and david perdue
get elected there because if you don't
if you want accountability
and not just a rubber stamp for a joe
biden cabinet
you need to have people like me as
chairman of the energy committee
so we'll have hearings ask the tough
questions but we are not going to forget
what happened
with president trump's administration
and the delayed
process that went through it the so it's
not going to be a garden party
if the republicans are in the majority
these nominees are going to have to run
the gauntlet
in terms of specific nominees that you
ask about
i'm from wyoming it's an energy state
here's my concern
when regards to energy joe biden has
repeatedly
said that he's against a lot of
exploration for energy a lot of
exporting
of energy so his nominee for the
secretary of energy
has said this she said we ought to be
doing everything
we possibly can to keep fossil fuel
energy
in the ground the impact of that on our
economy
on jobs it is it cuts the throat of my
state
our economy the men and women who work
there the energy that america needs it's
going to drive up costs
significantly for american families so
you bet i'm going to ask tough questions
finally president trump says that he
is going to veto the ndaa the
defense authorization act that funds the
pentagon
funds an air force base in your state of
wyoming and that includes 26
new measures that would deal with cyber
defense
this of course in the in in the wake of
this terrible cyber hack that we've
that we've had this week if the
president goes ahead with his promise
and he says he's going to veto it and he
would have to
by this wednesday will you vote to
override that veto sir
well first i would discourage him from
vetoing i would encourage him to sign it
especially with this new
cyber hack where we were blindsided
chris as a nation
six different agencies have been
attacked in our government
and this has been going on since march
we need to have a forceful effective
punishing response so people pay a price
for this
think twice about doing it again and one
of the things that the president could
do
in spite of his concerns about the
national defense authorization act
is to sign this let this bill become law
that's what my recommendation is to the
president
so he doesn't fight the situation of a
veto override
and in 15 seconds will you personally if
he goes ahead and vetoes as he says he
will
will you vote to override sir
we need to have this signed into law i'm
encouraging the president
to do that if it comes to the house and
and the senate
i'm going to be in a position where i'm
going to have to make that decision i
would it'd be much better for the
country
for the president to sign it
senator barrasso thank you thanks for
joining us good luck on coming up with
that deal you promised for today on
covet relief
and happy holidays sir going to get it
done merry christmas chris
thank you